hey everybody it's Keith's from iron
galaxy sitting here with Dale ratch also
from iron galaxy listen we wish we could
be there well Isaac is there but I wish
I could be there at PAX with you guys
instead you'll just have to deal with my
disembodied voice we want to show you in
a sock oh I want to show you what she's
all about she's our new character to KI
she's a grappler she's counter
characters she's got the spirit of a
samurai that's fantastic Isaac is going
to read some notes i'm going to perform
some stuff we're gonna have a little
back and forth and show you what his
Socko is all about whoa that girl losing
oh oh she's oh that's kind of scary I'm
gonna need a minute yeah okay I'm good
take 50 for take 50 for okay let's go
all right so let's start off with some
basic moon all right so hisako's walk
speed very very slow oh yeah prolly to
slowest them the game only crap yeah but
but she actually has a crazy forward ash
whoa yeah super fast one of the facets
of the game if not the fastest yeah so I
need control gotcha keep talking and so
basically her her low she has a low
profile when she does her her for like
water walls mean nothing to me ahhh it's
crazy good her back dash is actually
kind of her we move yeah it's not great
this is all right yeah she has a cool
i'll move called descent its back heavy
kick and you see what that does oh my
that is creepy holy great oh it's pretty
cool uh her jumps pretty average yeah
nothing real special not or not floaty
not fast just yeah it's just a jump she
actually has a really cool thing to she
can do when she jumps though oh wow go
to the corner over here check this out
you can actually wall jump off of your
opponent's wall this which has some
really neat applications which I'm sure
you guys will find you such as I can't
show you it's too much it's too much so
another really cool thing that she has
you notice right here in the UI is she
has this awesome programmer art oh you
are it's her ass meter yeah it's gonna
look a lot different when we're done but
right now it's just a yellow bar tell me
about wrath meteor Isaac
his wrath meter oh I'm glad you asked so
wrath meter is a meter she has when she
is her when she uses her naginata it
actually uses her heretics like going
down yeah asset why is it happening I
don't know but when I relax it comes
back and it seems like her body jitters
when it's full but when it's empty
there's no more jittery interesting I
wonder if that's a sign of what it is
keep going okay so hit me with your
naginata I'm gone and you have full
wrath yeah what was that I didn't even
push a button how do i get a counter yet
without a button well the raft meter is
full every hit from the naginata he is a
counter hit the light punches and light
kicks won't take away wrath leader but
they also won't counter it so next thing
that we should go on to is just for
normal so you already hit up well
there's there's a lot more with this
raft meter yeah I'll warn you in advance
but we're gonna talk about it as we go
yeah we got this sure all right let's
check out these normals what do we go we
got some of the most gnarly long-range
normals in the game here standing hard
punch standing medium punch standing
medium kick standing heavy kick
crouching heavy pick will get that bad
boy crouching heavy punch and crossing
medium punch are absolutely fantastic
anti airs the light buttons are all
right what else we have in here counter
hits counter hits for her most
characters get a little bit of frame
advantage and a little bit of extra
damage but counter hits for her saco are
massive amounts of extra frame advantage
in fact something like standing for a
hard kick here gives me enough frame
advantage to dash in and hit another
button in combo with very easy to
confirm off of her counter hits so keep
that in mind you're going to want to
keep that wrath full by relaxing which
is hard to do yet all these great
buttons you want to mash them but if you
do you're not going to get your counter
hits and other benefits from the meter
you want to show off her jumping text ya
her cross up jump.heavy-kick
jump.heavy-kick is a great cross up
you're walking with your quotes there we
go dump heavy punches spectacular range
jump medium punch jump medium kick all
very good moves very very useful for
kind of that mid-range footsie zoning
game which is great just great footsies
like the slow walk speed just because
you don't want to walk into this space
well I mean even if I try to jump like
watch what happened I hope that was not
I'm not attacking us
all right Hey look at that so good
they're great auntie airs yeah all right
what's the next what's the next thing
you want to talk about Isaac well we
should probably talk about her counters
she's a counter character as we
mentioned yeah what does that mean I'll
show you what that means you press all
three bunches counter high press all 36
the account or low go ahead and wind
kick me nope that was that was the worst
when kicked me yep Oh countered it and
the best thing about it go ahead and do
it again those are openers so you can go
straight into auto doubles or linkers
combo system Oh Hawaii why don't you
jump attack me hi counter oh oh
straighten to the combo system really
really powerful so one thing you can't
do is you're called vengeance counters
by the way you can't counter project
those no actually toss me I'm just gets
hit in the Pence can't counter throws so
go ahead and knock me over go for a
meaty throw I'm gonna counter it oh I'm
just kidding I get tossed so throws are
really good if you expect your opponent
to try and count the high counter will
catch high vengeance counter will catch
mids and overheads and the low counter
will catch mids and lows so mids you
don't really have to worry so much about
either either or will do so next up we
have Raph cancels this is another use of
the wrath meter oh yeah this is a big
deal so if you have over fifty percent
of this wrath meter you can cancel just
about anything she does even on this
into a into a counter so I missed this
and I counted right on out of our fifty
percent boom counter so we're playing
footsies I want to press standing hard
kick he jumps over it to attack me you
know cuz he reads it catch counter
cancer boom super scary stuff if you
manage to wrath and you take nice breaks
between your poke strings somebody will
try to punish you and you can reply it's
really great so I think now we're pretty
good to start moving on to her actual
special attack alright let's talk about
on Rios an yeah yeah these are rekha's
right they're kind of like orchids but
all three of the first hits whether you
do light medium or heavy those are going
to be mids after that you can go with
the light button you can
low you can go out twice you can go mids
for our overheads those are pretty easy
to see and counter i will show you in a
second heavy will do upward swipe that
catches anti-air and comes out a little
faster these are actually really slow
the the overheads in the lows you could
poke me between them so go ahead and
block the first it and then try and poke
me out of the low oh man I just get hit
straight up go ahead and try and poke me
out of the low again one more time ah
cash counter canceled so if you have
enough Raph you could counter cancel any
of your opponent's attempts to punish
even after the third one when you're
punishable at the end not between them
go ahead lock all these that's
punishable I can't block that but I
could catch counter cancel really really
scary stuff remember vengeance cancels
are where you make your opponent scared
to punish all the unsafe stuff that you
do and for the unreal Zen you can
actually mix and match that's an endured
yeah so I could go low overhead overhead
anti-air whatever you want to do after
the first one the second and third can
be absolutely whatever you want and you
can delay the time of a great deal to
get counter hits this stuff see big big
delay really cool spectacular range
extremely intimidating move and once
you've proved your opponent that you're
willing to catch counter all this on
safe stuff they start to clam up which
is great makes them scared this
character is all about making people
scared so next up we have the air
version of a lot of Sun real zone this
one actually changes their trajectory
that was the light/medium hops forward a
little bit and the heavy hops toward
even lower and those will take the
opponent out of the air easily but the
really cool thing is on counter hit or
with full wrath meter you get a
recapture off this thing so have some
really great kind of tiger knee advanced
setups for this hold still here what's a
cross cross that's nasty keep your eye
out for those those are really great
great great great frame advantage on
block on this move to if your opponent
does block this
well you're gonna get to do stuff yeah
very cool move recommend using it a lot
there's no shut over no shadow version
of that yeah look at the shadow versions
later mention shows a grappler yeah does
she have any command throws I would
assume so why don't you tell me about
the first one the first one is
influenced all right this is the fastest
man 3 it is the fastest commander in the
game it starts up at three frames Wow
the fastest other than that is five room
Wow yeah check it out it's pretty good a
great thing to do when you're in footsie
range here's where we're playing
footsies gotcha oh that is brutal
looking that's pretty good there's a
extra feature to this was full wrath did
you know that I I did know that if you
have full out of my notes when she
grabbed somebody this opens a combo so
I'm gonna go straight into a lotta level
here check that out so if you can manage
draft meter and grab somebody you get a
combo off that I grabbed instead of just
the raw damaged and cannot down it's
awesome yeah so in the medium version
slower start up yeah heavy version even
slower start up more do they have the
more damage and and has additional range
awesome great move next move is called
possession it's probably the scariest
move in the game we should we show them
first and this is why this is most
terrifying watch what happens ok I'm
playing and I just jump out of my seat
every time chase does this to me it's so
freaky it's kind of like running bear
grabbed but instead of me coming to get
you I make you come to me yeah if you
touch a Saco while she's pulling you in
if you like get too close she will just
trigger the command grab enter you
possess you break your bones and then
hop out which is really really cool it's
really easy to counter though as you're
sliding in you could just do like a lady
thick or something I just you could just
jump and hit me go ahead and jump you
pick me here so I went for wind kick all
right jumping kick me to try across that
maybe jump Hartman yeah there you go now
yeah try that again ok catch counter oh
oh there's very little more satisfying
in ki then using that move to make
somebody panic and I catch countering
their panic button it feels like
incredible it's so good she's extremely
scary it's so good sometimes you just
don't want to push book
throw into this really easily too if you
block low for me I like the bat push
people out pull them back in and get a
little bit of damage in a knockdown
really good stuff it's a great move I
guess we should that's all that's all a
special she's actually a really simple
character a lot of what she does is
about getting those grabs and trying to
set people up to press a button at the
wrong time so you can use a vengeance
counter yeah so next up is shadow moves
so let's start with her shed Oh unreal
Zen toss me a fireball yeah don't care
about that Wow project on going over a
long-range projectile vulnerable move
throw me another fireball oh good well I
pulled you passed your ass fireball the
inhale on possession shadow possession
is so fast yes okay sup very Hardy
accident really scares people it's a
great move yeah and of course I really
like shadow influence because the grab
normally has this kind of range but you
can get Thunder range with the shadow
immersion yeah so she crawls in all
creepy Boozer man grabs ran really
really good mood those are the shadow
moves yeah again pretty simple character
yeah really so next up we gotta linkers
in the end doubles all right so his saco
has a very interesting combat treat
where she can actually charge and delay
her medium and heavy auto bubble this is
the coolest I'm gonna go ahead and open
with a jump in so you can see it right
away this is the heavy Ottoman right now
I'm gonna charge it by holding the
button oh the cool thing about this is
that actually changes the timing of the
auto double to act as a manual all right
try and break the second hit yeah sure
you're the worst I know oh right you all
right now break it on timeless yeah sure
haha it's great counter breaker bait
I'll show you the medium one too here we
go that's medium punch the kicks also
have these but you can't do these that's
medium kick you cannot do these on the
light buttons like punching like kick
can't do a charge double only the
mediums lots of extra damage if you're
able to do it changes the timing to
manual but great counter breaker bait
very easy to break if you're not looking
for
so use those with a good mind for
counters as this character is meant to
do what else we got we got on Rios and
linkers obviously we can double at the
light linker medium under heavy linker
right yeah pretty soon pretty standard
she also has a linker on a quarter
circle back punch which is her influence
command grab but the animations not done
so we're going to show that one to you
today Enders she also has her a shadow
on real time oh yeah I can't break
because I'm the worst check it out oh my
god I'm the worst I don't wanna talk
about it here's shadow on Rios and yeah
I can try the worse it's really delayed
it's tough to break for people like
Isaac alright so moving on yeah let's go
to end reduce so this is your honor is
on is great yeah super wall sweat under
we're not here to wall but you can see
it again near the wall yeah you can see
how far that already pushes you yeah
well that's great to have as a grappler
the next one's my favorite actually if
you use influence as an Ender this is
going to give you a pretty long hard
knock down long enough to let your wrath
refill entirely so I like to use that
when I'm low on Raph that way when my
opponent wakes up we're back to a really
good position for me the other end are
obviously is going to be possession
right yeah this is her damage under this
this under looks really cool oh I love
that one lots of damage but your
opponent can get up pretty quick and
rejoin the fight so only is that when
you need damage or if your wrath is
already pretty close to full i would say
you're going to want to stick to the
other ones so you know next up we got
her instinct what could her instinct
mode be she already has so many
different utilities she does but if we
go into instinct mode ignore that it's
all their animation my wrath is not
going to go down at all and as you can
see every single hit as a counter hit
and that is also true in combos such as
these
that's the sickest combo ever it looks
like you could fall I will do more I
wonder but I won't today oh that was
five counter hits let's see what you
guys can do once you have this in the
wild the other really cool thing about
it is that hair counters like I
mentioned their high and low once you're
an instinct it doesn't matter go ahead
and hit low for me I countered high but
I still caught it counters are high low
ambiguous when you are an instinct mode
so you don't have to make a high-low
read on that and that is the Saco isn't
it yeah I mean so an instinct she has
pretty much the ability to do everything
that she requires wrath for right so you
could do to your attack you can also do
a catch counter app after that to do
wrath cancels pretty much all the time
you don't have to worry about anything
like that it's so good yeah it's great
that's the Saco thanks for joining us
guys I'm Keith's wish I was there this
is isaac he is there let's say hi to him
um and please enjoy saco when she comes
out